you don't like sunshine you don't like
warm weather owns I hear you're going to
Hawaii for the holidays why is that true
it is true I well woody harrelson who I
worked with back in the day on the
Hunger Games yeah he basically I was I
was talking I was like they might come
down to why and you just like like um to
keep a Hulu and again some ponds bro and
I was like okay yeah I'm coming out of
what you just said but cool man problem
I mean it's not like you were invited
yeah I think I was invited so I'm not
sure what if Woody Harrelson invites you
to his place in Hawaii have to go yeah I
think it's gonna be like how does he
live I don't know I heard all the time I
assumed nude forgiven nice assume that
he's like just constantly gardening and
smoking substances and just having a
great time bro yeah have you hung out
with it you haven't hung out with it
you've hung out with him in other
situations before I have but just
haven't hung out with him in Hawaii no I
think he has like a compound there I
think it's like him Willie Nelson and
Owen Wilson hey you know what when the
lips comes I'm going to that's where I'm
going
whatever its self-sustainable yeah yeah
just know exactly just probably identify
it by the thick cloud overhead so not a
mushroom cloud so they so they they all
live on this compound together more or
less and Woody is he's a really he's a
healthy guy right yeah it's a hyper
vegan what does that mean hyper vegan I
don't know it's great he's like I mean
he used to stop smoking yeah he doesn't
smoke marijuana anymore which is like I
don't even understand what that but he's
still gross he's probably eating massive
quantities of it well yeah they're
probably stuffed his turkey with it yeah
yeah probably but no he's like you know
he doesn't wearing like animal products
he doesn't like use any kind of
unnatural things on his body and he eats
all sustainable vegan healthy lifestyle
which is right I see one of those vegan
guys that insists that you be vegan no
not at all cuz I hate those yeah I've
had a cheeseburger in front of him and
I'm like woody have you ever tried one
of these and he's like yeah man like you
know 20 years ago right
and I was like yeah but they're better
now and I don't know my goal is one day
to maybe see if we eat a burger yeah
yeah that's actually a messed up go away
yeah this guy's made a bow and your goal
is to shove a mouth
you